inflation certainly taking a toll on all
of us especially business owners who in
many cases have to figure out how to
stay afloat right so our mary jane
ballieza is live at a family-owned farm
in the middle of the city talking about
the impact of those food and gas prices
on their business hi mary jane
hi there nate we're here at jr pony
parties in the northwest side of the
valley i'm joined bright and early this
morning with kathleen meehan her and her
family own this farm and kathleen thank
you so much for joining us
here good morning
good morning to dolly too she's oh my
gosh she's busy eating up all the grass
and everything here in the yard and
that's one thing as we know that
food costs for the animals have really
gone up i know for the price of hay you
were telling me has pretty much doubled
yeah it's gone up over a hundred dollars
what above what i used to pay
and that's and i just worry i know gas
may come down but does that gonna bring
our prices down i don't know i hope it
does but right now it's just i've had to
raise my prices in 25 years i've never
had to
raise my prices but i have to in 25
years i've got to to cover the cost of
taking care of the animals here well
that makes it hard too how can you keep
your business going you know if if you
can't do anything about that so you're
forced to raise your prices i'm forced
to raise my prices and i just hope with
you know the kids and everybody that
wants to come in here understand i had
to there's nothing i could do about it
and what people don't know either is
that you also take in rescue so you're
taking in more animals that means the
cost is going up for food and people
don't understand that that's a big
commitment it's a commitment of their
whole life so you take a horse or a pony
they live 30 years if not more or less
that is a commitment of your life for 30
years and you have to take that and that
with dogs and cats if you take an animal
in know that you have a commitment just
don't take it like oh i want to oh it's
so cute no it is a commitment of love
and
just take care of them oh yeah
absolutely and i can see how much love
you know you put into your animals and
dolly of course she's one of the she
look at her she's just pretty much eaten
away you can tell she's pretty committed
to to being here as well because she's
just so good with the kids like you were
mentioning she is so good and she's well
loved and she's always asked for or we
got some others out there that always
ask for too we people have their
favorites and we we will bring out their
favorites eight i mean you're absolutely
right i'm here in the northwest valley
in the part of town i am joined bright
early this morning with kathleen meeham
her and her family owned jr pony parties
and of course we have another special
guest here with
ellie mae
she's already looking at me wondering if
i have any food oh and i do have some
food
and kathleen i know we talked a lot
about the inflation impacts on your
business especially with birthday
parties i mean it's been slow this
summer for you it's been really slow and
i get it it's hot but you know what guys
the weather's changing it's going to
start getting cooler because my guys are
already shedding so i know winter's
coming and you know book your birthday
parties they're private they're uh three
hours and we run the whole venue we make
a big deal out of the birthday child but
we also put parents back to the party so
they don't miss out on anything which is
important because sometimes when we're
running around for our kids we miss out
on those special times but we're going
to put you back in there lots of pony
rides the petting zoo the goats feeding
animals it's a blast here and as we know
too i mean with any type of business
you're hopefully waiting for it to pick
up as september comes that way you can
keep the animals going as well because a
lot goes into it you got to pay for
their food and you also take in other
animals as well absolutely it takes a
lot of time and a lot of money and a lot
of food to keep these guys all
comfortable and living happy
and you do take donations too yes we do
and they can just send them to jay our
pony parties our address is on our
website that's perfect i know she's
probably wanting more grass here as well
right or they can give me a call too
702-631-4142
that's perfect well kathleen thank you
so much appreciate it for having me
thank you for coming and seeing my
animals perfect reporting live mary jane
ballasa live local now